and
and uh each of these diseases you can
think of as uh
and also including terrorist attacks and
school shootings for example
things which lead to fatalities you can
look at
as problems that could be solved
and some problems are harder to solve
than others
i mean that's part of the equation so
maybe if you look at these diseases if
you look at heart disease or cancer
or alzheimer's or just
like schizophrenia and obesity w like
not necessarily things that kill you but
affect the quality of life
which problems are solvable which aren't
which are harder to solve which aren't i
love your question because it puts it in
the context
of a global um effort
rather than just a local effort so
basically if you look at
the global aspect exercise
and nutrition are two interventions that
we can as a society
make a much better job at so if you
think about sort of the availability
of cheap food it's extremely high in
calories
it's extremely detrimental for you like
a lot of processed food etc
so if we change that equation and
as a society we made availability of
healthy food much much easier
and charged a burger at mcdonald's
the price that it costs on the health
system
then people would actually start buying
more healthy
foods so basically that's sort of a
societal intervention if you wish
in the same way increasing empathy
increasing education increasing the
social framework
and support would basically lead to
fewer suicides
it would lead to fewer murders it would
lead to fewer
you know deaths overall um so
you know that's something that we as a
society can do you can you can also
think about external factors versus
internal factors so the external factors
are basically communicable diseases
like covid like the flu etc and
the internal factors are basically
things like you know cancer and
alzheimer's where basically your your
genetics will eventually
you know drive you there um and then
of course with all of these factors
every single disease has both a genetic
component
and environmental component so heart
disease you know huge then they
contribute
contribution alzheimer's it's like you
know
60 plus genetic
so i think it's like 79 heritability
so that basically means that genetics
alone explains
79 of alzheimer's incidence
and yes there's a 21 environmental
component
where you could basically enrich your
cognitive environment enrich your social
interactions read more books learn a
foreign language
go running you know sort of have a more
fulfilling life
all of that will actually decrease
alzheimer's but there's a limit to how
much that that can impact
because of the huge genetic footprint
you